new logo same epilepsy also 30 seconds
of logo establishing shots of Washington
DC are not complete without at least one
monument and one jogger I left also does
cat need to run laps to stay in shape
isn't it that concoction of superhero
steroids that keeps him powerful even
after 60 years of being in a coma I
guess he could have gotten bored but
damn go fight crime or something cyclist
the running in the movie started on some
bridge crossing the Potomac how did
Steve run the exact same course that Sam
was running to lap him three times in
three different locations they weren't
running around the reflecting pool the
whole time that's for damn sure
Internet so health except for BuzzFeed
this is a funny list of things that
Steve needs to catch up on but who just
randomly told him check out Steve Jobs
of Apple Inc what you learn may surprise
you
man so glad they included the latitude
and longitude or else I would have been
lost is he a superhero or is he born
because in this opening sequence it's
tough to tell the difference warning
ride may cause vomiting sure everything
up to this point has been covert done
with the maximum amount of sensitivity
so it was about time cap threw his
shield through the wheelhouse so that
the bad guy could be alerted to his
presence badass or no one measly kick is
enough to keep cap from nabbing this guy
sure would have been great if he had his
shield with him right now play into the
dystopian basic playground taunting is
enough to enter cap into this let's
fight without weapons cliche also how
the fuck does cap have time to learn
French when he still hasn't even seen
Star Trek what the fuck is going on is
cap not a super soldier with
super-strength cap went toe to toe with
Iron Man in the Avengers so why are
regular human dudes suddenly a match for
him yeah but what are its coordinates
now last time I trusted someone I lost
an eye you trusted the safety of earth
to the Avengers you assembled to save
New York even at the point of blowing up
a u.s. plane that was gonna bomb New
York so you trust people all the time
ask every week some punk would say
what's in the bag would he do I don't
know cap maybe if you'd let him finish
the story he'd tell you Stark
oh you had a few suggestions once he got
an up-close look at our old turbines
Marvel continues to think merely
mentioning the other Avengers in these
standalone movies will be all the
audience needs to stop wondering why the
other Avengers aren't actually helping
out in this movie's crisis the
satellites can read a terrorist DNA
before he steps outside a spider hole
even if I'm willing to give you that
magic satellite that also means you
somehow have a database with the DNA of
every person in the world matched to an
identity and that's not acceptable in
any way at all
we've now seen enough movies with Chris
Evans in them to start saying Chris
Evans is on a motorcycle cliche Steve
goes to learn about himself before
learning about Steve Jobs and Apple only
one little boy recognizes cap at his own
exhibit best friends since childhood
Bucky Barnes and Steven Rogers
were inseparable by the hood this
childhood best friend and fellow soldier
merit his own wing in the Captain
America museum I know the movie wants to
suddenly make Bucky super important but
I doesn't mean the world would have the
mess we can do its DeSoto sir cap just
happens to visitors would have been
girlfriend right before her imminent
death when we think less of this movie
if they didn't have Holograms talking to
Nick Fury is this our future I hope not
Holograms look awful in every movie
unless they're used for trickery in Thor
the dark world then they just don't make
sense please like this raises serious
question like Marvel Poe chooses
secondary villain from the best DC movie
ever even at 193 years old Robert
Redford can still act any of the rest of
this movie stars under the table you got
to get Iron Man to stop by my niece's
birthday party Iron Man for niece's
birthday party now wonder down he didn't
want to do it look who it is
the running man Arnold Schwarzenegger
must have that Benjamin Button condition
that this is help geez holograms on the
car windshield - that's not only useless
but what I call distracted driving
recommend anesthetic injection and also
remind you that this high-tech
state-of-the-art vehicle is a Chevy
these shady military goons brought in a
battering ram instead of say I don't
know explosives to destroy this car I'd
like to see these guys shoot out the
tires for once
who knows maybe they skimped on
automatic tire inflation technology and
you can kill Nick Fury instead of
whatever this is I was even bothering to
drive this God car in the first place
shady government goons take shooting
lessons from the projections in
Inception when her soldier dude just
happens to be waiting for Nick on this
random street also he's not only doing
his best Joker from Dark Knight
imitation but also waiting all these
needless minutes while his underling
assassins flail around before stepping
in to do the job himself that seems like
a perfectly handy weapon the other bad
guys could have used earlier
he brought his lightsaber that thing cut
an escape tunnel through first his
unkillable vehicle and second through
the street and into the ground in like
five seconds plus it was able to
displace a giant pile of rubble that
carving such a tunnel would create also
I suppose the Winter Soldier didn't just
go ahead and climb down into the tunnel
and chase after an extremely injured man
with no weapons he said I guess my work
is done here and bounced kathan America
is worldwide famous and has his own wing
at the Smithsonian but no fans are
paparazzi are staking out his residue
at all it's probably because they
respect his privacy right is this the
movies end credits sequence so do you
bad guys finally find their aim when
it's surprising to the audience don't
trust in what I bet he means that
asshole Walter Donovan from the Last
Crusade also other people you shouldn't
trust Iron Man Thor honk or any of the
other superheroes you would instantly
call in this situation if you were a
logical human being Captain America is a
dick to office spaces jump down for what
the hell are you giving up for how far
could he possibly have gotten in the
last three seconds I mean this is
definitely an elaborate hoax right I
can't imagine why Marvel would want to
kill off Nick Fury or samuel l.jackson
saying I don't want to do any more of
these highly profitable movies steeples
at a secret flash drive in full view
because I guess he needs reminding that
he has this flash drive in his pocket
some of you may not be aware but when a
person dies the hospital wheels them
into a side room so that that person's
employees can silently mourn the carcass
for a few minutes
need to take him because he's definitely
not dead I mean why else would Maria
Hill be in this movie other than to take
Nick Fury to his secret bunker where he
can pop out and introduce us to the
events of Avengers 2 strike move it out
never before has the timing of a
concession vending machine refilled job
been so perfect also this is Ireland the
worst hiding place in the world for a
flash drive or it's a biting indictment
on how few people buy hubba bubba bad
guys decide to be annoying and make the
elevator stop down every floor to
collect reinforcements movie villains
send regular humans to try and kill cap
in an elevator because the movie doesn't
want to fuck it only wants some cheap
foreplay he's headed for the garage
locked down the bridge steve manages to
run into the garage get his motorcycle
drive off and still get to the bridge in
time before they lock it down I'm
confused I know he's super strong and
the shield is basically indestructible
but how is the shield also a boomerang
is the movie saying he's just so gifted
with hand-eye coordination that he
always throws it perfectly so it careens
back to him too bad shield only has one
of those hover plane things if someone
tweets about this guy I want to know
about it tweeting Captain Rogers has
information regarding the death of
director fury refused to share it so we
tried to kill him
rather than arrest him and interrogate
it how does she know to come back to the
hospital and check the vending machine
Nick Fury wasn't there anymore she left
before cap hid the flash drive and she's
not one of the bad guys
paranoia only works when the shady
action makes sense most of the
intelligence community doesn't believe
he exists the ones that do call him the
winter
soldier roll credits I was escorting a
nuclear engineer out of Iran somebody
shot out my tires definitely not any bad
guys then the drive has a level 6 homing
program so as soon as we boot up she'll
know exactly where we are question is
with such an important flash drive why
don't they have a homing beacon that
works without booting up how much time
we have about nine minutes
um now nine minutes for a level six
homing program Jesus how slow is level
three that is a huge ass fucking
arbitrary window of time how do we know
they're evil ladies and gentlemen
because they're in black trucks riding
single-file and tailgating shields only
available agents to pursue number one
fugitive Steve Rogers are all the way
back at headquarters
so I guess Natasha just calculated the
drive time from headquarters to the mall
to come up with that ridiculous nine
minute window public displays of
affection make people very uncomfortable
bad guys don't notice obvious incognito
good guys because the power of other
people's boners is stronger funhouse
mirror Chris Evans the coordinates are
the same base where cap was trained but
he's still only slightly cautious again
if he'd spent more free time catching up
on movies instead of memorizing
nonfiction bullshit he'd know he's
walking right into a trap
there's Starks father Howard where the
fuck is Roger Sterling assholes how are
you just gonna recast younger Howard
Stark and forget all about the badass
you had playing the character earlier
Jesus first they had to trace the drives
origin then they had to spot the on a
police fake munitions bunker then they
had to notice the small rush of air
indicating a passageway I'm beginning to
think this villain that wants to be
found doesn't actually want to be found
even if her advanced cell phone has an
app that can do this it's still only
indicating the four most often pressed
numbers not the order of the President
so Natasha instantly pressing them in
the correct order is a middle finger and
I'm just gonna give you one right back
shall we play a game it's for long movie
that might pop so Steve seemed fine
wargames before seeing Star Trek what we
did not realize was that if you try to
take that freedom they resist you
honestly believe that did you sit around
in a room somewhere thinking you know
what I love when people tell me what to
do the new Hydra grew a beautiful
parasite inside
why is the evil Hydra science guys
brain-computer giving up an exposition
dump to the movies heroes it's because
the audience need to be filled in on
okay let's lure Steve to this place so
we can tell him everything about our
plan before killing him
brilliant that's impossible Sheldon has
stopped you accidents will happen is
that what he's calling Nick Fury's death
because no investigator would consider
hot LED blasting through an apartment
wall to be an accident least I hope not
project insight requires insight so I
wrote an algorithm what kind of
algorithm I don't know Natasha and maybe
if you let the disembodied brain of dr.
Zola finish he'd tell you they survived
this also Pierce calculates this plan to
ridiculous detail except the idea that
cap might think quick enough to survive
the missile attack crawl in the acid why
not just calling the asset in the first
place
also why fire only one missile that's
Captain America right maybe you should
think about overkill in this case I'm
going to go mr. Pierce mr. Pierce's may
decides she'll yell through the wall
right next door instead of walking 5
feet to see him face to face because man
but that every bad is she witnessed the
Winter Soldier on the other side he
already cost me Zola actually you cost
you Zola there was no need to blast the
building he was in you could have easily
waited until they got outside for a
surprise attack you could have just gone
ahead and used this dude in the first
place
Oh wish you would have knocked villain
kills innocent person unnecessarily
because it's time for the audience to
know he's evil cliche hey I met you once
while running and then again at a
recovery group meeting so I
automatically know where you live I mean
did they even exchange full names and it
sure was nice that Steve ran the exact
same route that Sam did that one random
morning useful ooh friend is useful well
Jesus I'll shoot no these top secret
army wings to which I as a civilian will
instantly be granted access or at the
very least my theft of them will be
glossed over completely passing truck
driver honks is horn because assholes
you get thrown into traffic are a menace
to society also aren't they saying that
the Winter Soldier can fly where the
hell did he come from later we find out
there's a Jeep full of bad guys but that
Jeep is way far back in the action so he
didn't come from the Jeep the Winter
Soldier could have taken out this car no
problem with that thing he used earlier
to blow up Nick Fury's SUV but now we
have to know how badass he is with a
number of unnecessary stunts he can pull
off there should be a tremendous traffic
jam going the other way after that huge
truck slammed this at well just a second
ago
rubberneckers would be out in force um
when your body careens and tumbles
across asphalt like this you get up with
most of your skin gone but in the movie
he only gets a few scratches
because Falcon now that the hanging on
top of the car cliche Bulls didn't work
now it's time for a grenade launcher
something that could totally have done
the job in the first place
oh good you have more of these I was
beginning to worry you only had the one
anyway good timing okay so Natasha is
running underneath a four-lane bridge
she's running running more running still
running
how fucking why does this bridge and how
long does it take someone to run
underneath it yeah cap that fall must've
made you groggy we've seen you survive
worse no problem but sure you go ahead
and take a rest now
you deserve it okay so we know that
Steve is in this bus but the bad guys
can't know that he's in the bus Winter
Soldier dude shot Captain America he
went flying over the bridge but no one
was around to confirm where he landed
and they spent the last couple of
minutes trying to kill Natasha and Sam
with this incredibly high-powered weapon
be able to fire so many rounds at the
boss without at least a few making it
through and killing cap because at the
bottom of buses are not cooking strong
why are they even bothering to try this
and why aren't more things made out of
bus bottles also yet another weapon the
bad guys pull out that could have ended
this a whole lot earlier also DC police
might be bad but this is the most
negligent Police Force since the NOP D
in x-men origins Wolverine Steve jumps
out of the bus and what do you know his
shield is lying right there tardiness
also gotta give Sam something to do
right why not leave one guy on the
bridge who has no business being up here
so he can fight him bad guys keep
shooting a cap shield as he walks
towards them and uses said shield to
deflect bullets and kill them all
instead of you know shooting at his legs
also sure was convenient to the run
length of this movie that the Winter
Soldier decided to go after etosha
instead of killing cap himself right
here and now police response time Josh I
have a pizza delivery hey remember when
you're on top of the car minute ago
dropping one of these babies in it and
simply jumping off the car would have
been an easy thing to do to accomplish
your mission any of these people know
what the way is to stay out of it and
there she warning as many characters in
the first movie as they can into this
aren't they next up DNA strands of Hugo
Weaving connected to an oak tree the
stalks also surprise except so not
surprised that it makes you wonder why
they even bother to put this reveal so
late in the film Sam swoops in to save
cap because he totally knew where these
guys were after being on top of the
bridge the whole time ah so Bucky
escaped in the smoke of that explosion
like a cheesy magician then gotcha
he's the Burt Winter stone soldier where
the fuck at these assholes been the
whole time hanging back yeah I know he
notices the chopper in a minute and
tells them to put their guns
so they don't get on the news murdering
camp but no one cared about the news
during the whole Bucky thing and no one
knew about the chopper at this point
when they're walking up telling him to
get on his knees so what the fuck not
here but maybe in the van on the way
over to wherever you're going right they
need to get a doctor here Maria Hill
waits until Sam asked for medical
attention before finally revealing
herself was she gonna wait until the
cars stopped to tell everyone hey guys
friend here to help also I see now I
guess the reason they didn't kill them
and only took them prisoner was so that
we could have the surprise agent hill
rescue fine okay whatever I know you
guys all loved this movie and that's
fine but I hope you realize it makes
about as much sense as a terry gilliam
fever dream this is that he's the future
new Captain America duh well Lisa's
character is they'll probably replace
the actor with Don Cheadle we all start
didn't I see these bad guys went to the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull school of
putting the heroes in the rear vehicles
so no one can see the escape also why
entrust anyone except yourself to watch
these guys in the back of the van that
was bad intelligence very bad
intelligence wait was this magic van
underneath the street in the tunnel they
escaped from or did they escape through
the bottom of the prison van and then
run out the back without anyone noticing
them and then find another van somewhere
because either scenario is simple as I
promised is the first time I've seen
this movie unfortunately for this movie
I've seen lots of other movies it caught
you up and your heart stopped dead to
the toxin B hey that's the same bull
toxin Liam Neeson used in the 18 a
pretty shirt doesn't have that
convenient use but at least it sounds
good but an evil medical lab is inside a
bank safe deposit box vault because it
looks cool shot into pods
yeah about that remember in the first
Captain America when they were on the
train well dr. Zola was also on that
train and they caught him not long after
Bucky's fall and they took him to an
interrogation room where Tommy Lee Jones
ate steak in front of him he definitely
wasn't there for Bucky's Winter Soldier
surgery and I'm calling bull found
anyone else walking around looking for
Winter Soldier candidates at that time
bunch of superheroes come up with a
Mission Impossible style plan involving
swapping out guidance chips instead of a
plan where cap infiltrates the carriers
one at a time and punches their engines
until they fall out of the sky also
seriously the only reason Fury isn't
calling Ironman right now is because
Robert Downey jr. is too damn expensive
so thanks Marvel for giving us this
massive cinematic universe that only
makes sense during the Avengers films
I'm listening to the end of the line pal
irony also what a great scene it shows
us the friendship that we already knew
existed and adds extra time to a movie
that's over two hours superb
no you you will because the power of
friendship is stronger oh man I am so
fired
I wish also why did cat need to steal
this museum suit when he escaped shield
headquarters he had the suit on the next
time we see him is in the hospital
wearing civvies so obviously he hid the
current suit somewhere and should be
able to get it back instead movie has
him steal one because King Stanley
well of course you are the heroes have
to show up in time to stop it so you
couldn't have done this any earlier
that's for sure Kate Falls for this
I guess they consulted golden eye on how
to build humongous underwater things
gymnastics dodging I was just about to
give this movie some sin points back for
having this surprise badass older lady
destroying all these dudes
but then this Mission Impossible happens
and well I'm suddenly thrust back into
the brain-dead Academy School of Arts
also once again technology that could be
extremely useful for both sides is used
for one surprise attack for movie
purposes state-of-the-art
next-generation helicarriers are hella
bad at aiming well even if one of those
one of the time dudes had fired their
guns this whole thing would be over BAM
evil wins Hydra watch star wars saw the
completely unguarded glaring weakness in
the Death Star and said hey let's set up
our own vulnerability to be similarly
deserted couldn't they just throw a
grenade in one of these things and do
the exact same job quicker later they're
gonna blow these helicarriers out of the
sky anyway so why don't they just blow
up the control panel why Bucky ditch the
goggles and mouth guard part of his
uniform is it because Steve knows his
true identity out because Bucky doesn't
know that remember how he was
brainwashed again last night
sailing the encryption is an executive
order it takes two alpha level members
don't worry
company's coming on cue explainatory
helicopter lands just outside right as
she says this what the is going on fury
has a separate security clearance for
his eyeball how would it be connected in
the system to his identity but not
noticed by Pierce when he was wiping
former director fury security clearance
oh come on you just debated tons of
anti-aircraft fire earlier now you're
gonna get nabbed by something as clunky
as a grappling hook Winter Soldier says
it will let gravity decide this
Oh No there wasn't nearly enough time
for that parachute to break your fall I
see this Helicarrier was built with
movie fights in mind unless you wanted
to inch holding your sternum I put that
gun down why didn't you just do this
before like when this was happening sure
she punched you in the face but how long
would it have taken to get that handy
remote and fry our ass that was armed
the moment you pinned it on but why were
you afraid that when the council members
learned what you were doing within sight
they'd blast their way out of shield and
go tell the world about your plans I
really need some fucked up way to make
sure they don't do that I know badges
that burn through sternums
god I'm a genius discount rocky three
and the movie hasn't even ended yet see
getting choked unconscious gave Bucky
his aim back followin ready man I hope
they do that thing where they're ready
to fire but it still takes him a while
just to add tension firing in three I
don't know but why you have these ships
lock now they pose no danger this is a
hero sacrifices himself to save the
world cliche but the world is already
safe jeez Michael Bay thinks this
sequence of explosions is excessive
I guess it's lucky none of these ships
crashed in downtown Washington right
also by the way is anyone in Washington
giving a shit about this just a minute
ago we saw these things targeting
everyone in the city including the
president who was nice and cozy at the
White House apparently unconcerned about
all the explosions he was hearing
earlier and none of the debris landed on
or endangered anyone except bad guys the
final Helicarrier somehow is a sense of
poetic justice deciding to crash
directly into the bad guy headquarters
jeez they're still fighting
why doesn't anybody won yet why not he
had no idea where the helicopter was and
the helicopter had no idea where he was
and even though he lands headfirst into
a helicopter door he survives this don't
worry I'm sure they'll find that
one-of-a-kind item before the next
Avengers movie somehow Gizem Lithia did
you know well here's one of our
favorites the old character repeats
dialogue back at the person who said it
to him this time with extra subtext
routine
it's a classic annoyance movie continues
to think I haven't seen other movies
before and pretend Steve isn't gonna be
saved at the last minute by Bucky as you
can see the US military DC police
firefighters and so on have jumped all
over this crisis in downtown Washington
it's a trick Steve it's 70 more years
into the future that guy you think is
Sam is wearing one of those things
etosha wore a minute ago to pretend that
he's Sam you're not gonna put any of us
in a prison you know why probably
because you're so going to stall face ha
ha pulp fiction reference he'll probably
strike down
upon me with great die hard with a
vengeance and nick furious anger am i
right masturbatory fanboy evil weapon
technology that half the audience will
have to google to learn about elizabeth
Olsen is at my girlfriend in this mid
credit sequence and credit scene expects
me to be surprised that Bucky is out
there but Dan we saw him drag cap to the
edge of the water and walk off into the
sunset so I mean yeah Donal II he's out
there also in the movies second end
credits sequence Bucky goes to learn
about himself before he even learns
about Steve Jobs and Apple
there is one more thing
top marks led by this guy XD GSE we are
an unarmed Vega we have two skiffs
approaching with armed intruders
potential privacy situation
pln rebels took the embassy and security
got me out how come you didn't get
caught I went out for pizza then I went
to Canada people do you have any idea
who you're dealing with
this is Jason Bourne you are nine hours
behind the toughest target you have ever
tracked why yes yes
shall we play a game hello neo who are
you I am the architect I created the
matrix I've been waiting for you the
battle station is heavily shielded and
carries a firepower greater than half
the Starfleet its defenses are designed
around a direct large-scale assault a
small one-man fighter should be able to
penetrate the outer defense
you
attention all shield agents this is
Steve Rogers I may not be a
masterbuilder I may not have a lot of
experience fighting or leading or coming
up with plans we're having ideas in
general do you believe it now Trinity